can you talk about your dumb dragon show
yo I swear to God
virgin dorks
where am I to me because I was looking
at the different size dragons from House
of dragons to the Game of Thrones
yesterday I had a [ __ ] graph built up
yeah yeah I know you have to make that
grab for no [ __ ] didn't have to do that
[ __ ] is already available on YouTube oh
wow I literally had the whole thing the
dragons in House of Game of Thrones
nothing bro oh wow nothing compares to
yourself that's your little Kia compared
to the real [ __ ] they got Ferraris in
House of dragons Valerian The Dread bust
out belarian the dread when Valerian The
Dread comes through now compare right
now we haven't even seen Valerian The
Dread and House of dragons dorks
that's Valerian the tread right there
that little [ __ ] you can't even see
that's what we was [ __ ] with in Game
of Thrones so dragons got smaller yes
over time stupid yes bro that's so dumb
what do you mean it's dumb
and what the dragon Den what was that
the dragon Den that actually makes sense
though right all the animals got smaller
over here they actually became bats or
what yeah basically look look at the
size of a whale now go look at the size
of a [ __ ] Valerian the dress oh
that's scary
[ __ ] aiming guys
that's the biggest dragon they think is
around the dread is somewhere else and
they don't know where that [ __ ] is you
nerd I thought we saw Valerian no you
saw vegar
well you want me to ruin it for you no
no you might have seen the little shadow
of it you've seen him yeah really he's
dead
the Larry and the dragon he's the big uh
he's the big skull they keep walking by
[ __ ] remember they said that there was
one dragon that went away and they
didn't know where it was what happened
to all the momentum on your little rant
there God damn I don't think he's dead
yet hey thanks miles no he's not you
[ __ ] crackers
yo listen all I'm trying to say if you
look at caraxi's you look at melicks you
look at sirax like you look at all these
dragons they are [ __ ] Great Ghost is way
bigger than any of the dragons that
Khaleesi had are you naming one of your
kids after one of these dragons 100 oh
that'd be fire 100 some of these names
are sick if I have a daughter I'm naming
a quicksilver 100
I'm naming my daughter Quicksilver 100
yo quickie
that's how we were made
um is the show actually good or not yeah
the show was good it had two week
episodes that [ __ ] Laris dude that
everybody says the combination of me and
you mark who loves feet you know my man
still loves feet waxing
I have a fundamental issue with the
character lyrics strong do you know the
guy I'm talking about no but you're
talking about so talk to me club foot
okay got it so club foot beats off to
Queen Alex called him unusual suspects
yeah he does look like he looks like
Kaiser everyone thought of you in that
moment yeah I know everybody was
thinking about me but it was man that's
crazy because they made him look like a
freak weirdo instead of an a complete
chess genius what do you think he would
look like when he obsessed and Over Feet
Brian looking like that real one a real
real one a real one I see you looking
like a real one y'all out here dating
girl when you watch House of dragons
don't even like feet that's the weirdest
[ __ ] ever son is what's crazy to me is
that there are people that date women
and don't even look at their feet that's
crazy that's not to me it's crazy what
actually bothered me is that shorty
didn't have any toenail polish on they
didn't do polish bags it's like 1300.
it's make believe man just make they got
makeup back then they got lipstick back
then you don't think they could put
something off on the flesh color they
ain't even do Contour yet bro the
Kardashians
no but what I'm saying is you couldn't
put something on the toes but they don't
even give us the good shot of the toes
it's like profile from far away or like
from the bottom of them oh you they need
a foot guy to direct it I already had my
dick out Laris was late last Super
League wait so what's the angle that you
want us to tell
sure and then she takes off the
stockings and then you kind of see
Phoebe you can't see toenail length you
can't see any of these things I don't
even know if it's her feet I thought you
saw all that no you didn't was it [ __ ]
that gets you guys off when it's like
when they you see the bottom and they
wiggle it
[Applause]
was that I think it actually do you like
Tarantino yes do you like no that he
includes feet in every single one of
course yeah
Uma Thurman walking wiggling the big toe
wiggling the big toe and uh that's how
she got not paralyzed in the in the
Vampire movie he's got his foot in his
mouth he drinks off her foot yeah of
course you've never done that you've
never put a blunt in between a girl's
toes which uh Dawn of the Dead uh no
Dustin
yeah of course like as a problem
they're like oh yeah
and he goes oh I'll do it yeah he goes
yeah let me suck it yeah he's the man
live your dreams create your reality I
didn't like what he did Margot Robbie's
Pizza don't make them all [ __ ] dirty
that's that was yeah I'm not into the
dirty feet what's the angle y'all want
to see I want to see the foot directed
House of dragon what happens
if Tarantino directed a house of dragons
obviously the toes would have been
painted it would have been shot from
like above so you're seeing the whole
foot and lyrics right there which is
what I wanted good toes too we need good
toes but I don't like this character
Laris like if you have a club foot if
you have any sort of deformity you make
up for it in your personality that's why
Tyrion was great right he was the most
Charming charismatic smart guy because
he was a [ __ ] he had to be this
hilarious guy is a club-footed weirdo
that looks and acts like a weirdo it's
two on the nose do you know what I'm
saying like a whole season like have
your personality reflect the
difficulties in your life like I I'm
okay with like a like a rich prince
being a weirdo like the guy who's uh
aegon who's King now right because his
life is perfect so of course he's into
this weird like kids fighting with those
sharp nails and shark teeth he's just
like a degenerate but if you have a
deformity you are making up for it in
every aspect of life not just being a
slimy weirdo it feel it falls into a
soap opera every time I see that guy I
feel bad saying that because this is his
like greatest achievement in life
well I would say that he makes character
choices as well but I don't know that I
try to give you an out I know you didn't
really do that one I know you did I know
you did but you know what I'm saying
like I I'm assuming that they make some
decisions right I don't know you know
you you read the the books
no he stopped reading it once he heard
the black people in it
[Music]
[Laughter]
is like uh no one suspects that he's can
do anything so that's why he plays like
that like Horrible character and then
he's the master of of spiders he's the
the guy who knows everything so he's
what I play Coy play innocent don't play
slimy little he plays innocent to people
he plays slimy to her because she knows
who what he really does but when he's
talking to like anyone else he's like oh
hi he's he's like take a shower you know
like the old dude that used to walk like
that I thought of him yeah yeah yeah
okay what were your thoughts of the
episode where were you guys thoughts
anybody who saw it you didn't see it yet
you didn't see it yet Alex I'm just
talking I mean it was good
um it wasn't as good as a week prior but
like you kind of really suspected
everything that was gonna happen even
Shorty at the end with the dragon yeah
really yeah you knew that was gonna
happen I kind of don't know what you're
talking about right now
I'm like did I finish it
shorty busts into the oh yeah yeah but
you see her dipping off you know that
where she's going Oh I thought she was
out
nah she said she wanted to go to the
dragon she said she wanted to do yeah
fair enough I don't know I like the show
I think it's great I'm excited for the
next episode and I'm in they saved it
they had two Bad episodes in a row and
that was scaring me because it was about
to be dunzo but they I think they're
finishing strong I wish the brother took
him out and he became king that [ __ ] oh
please believe me all that's gonna
happen yeah but that [ __ ] would have
before he did it right there yeah yeah
they took a gamble HBO took a gamble
they could have started the the whole
show now and then just done flashbacks
to set it all up yeah but they squeezed
another season out of it so it's a
gamble because if it doesn't work you
don't have a show but if it does work
you have an extra season
so they they [ __ ] just pulled it off
right because now we're back on board
we're curious and I think this next
episode sets up what I believe is I know
you guys are [ __ ] nerds you don't
know about this [ __ ] but the dance of
the Dragons yeah when they start beefing
hard oh [ __ ] yeah can you wait till 2024
for the next season is that what they're
saying yeah they're saying it's not till
2024. God why oh this is the last time
we gotta talk about this thing no no BTS
no housing dragons
[Music]
what are we gonna do Mark what are we
going to do Ornery on Sunday I'm gonna
be super ornery